nella puntata precedente mio cane come
personaggi o verso scegliamo il mio cane
ma cosa cercava h 10 per cento e non
importa va affatto bene
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono famigerati siamo dati su di
escape east se non apro gli occhi mai
non riuscirò mai ad evadere di prigione
ci proviamo con ciccio e pietro let's go
troppo tardi da solo ma vai e non c'è
tempo cosa aspetti non c'è tempo apri
recato nelle grafiche sfigato
porca vacca morta porca liberati non li
mortacci vostri per lasciatemi la lima
due ragazze ragazzi allora e scopri come
si trovano gli oggetti e portano i due
era sotto l'iva che faccia venire tieni
quando dobbiamo uscire le portiamo sono
qua dice un tizio ufficio e mi
raccomando la vita cittadina
vorrei fermo nuziale allora che se parti
poi ciceri buoni dentro aspetta l'ok
rubik che non viene concesso
poi è arrivato niente danni riparati
ritorno in cella e riteniamo di delle
madri interni cioè velocemente le case
un ottimo potuto nascondere una volante
è tempo ancora certa prova nascondi
reali ma nasconde appena finisce il
allerta prendiamo il limes capiamo che
comunque di cimiteri che forzare poi
prenderò la prendete tutto quanto
permette fa spesso espresso come soffre
una stessa adesso andiamo comunque un
problema
appena ci vai mai veloci veloci
procedendo vice calcano i cani o ha
fatto già caldo mi ha steso va benissimo
c'è un calcio fatto fuori tutti ma anche
perché avevamo alla sicurezza aumentata
capitato a fare i ragazzi per un po e
poi
perché a macchia che è difficile
difficilissima qualcosa o no grazie
ancora sbagliamo una cosa dove stava
scavando nei adesso c'è una torretta
sotto davvero siamo dei [ __ ] meglio
che stia uscire gli ho visti uscire
dall'edificio si può stiamo per fuggire
dal momento lega tutti in linea allora
la tattica è questa io odio o una banana
un latte un cacciavite e una lametta e
poi in stanza c'è una lima per tagliare
la al muro adesso facciamo l'appello ci
mandano dormire dopo che ci vadano a
dormire svitiamo il rosso come faresti
la xvi chiamo noi cosa abbiamo da
perdere facciamo lo stesso ragazzi del
gioco e si rifugiano fuggiamo parli
diversa lì sul tavolo e svita aspetta
aspetta aspetta aspetta prima le coperte
devono essere trasformate ok diciamo da
dove al centro da quando al centro
legale stato io
al centro c'è gente è l'unico per uscire
da questo pronti lega si corre ore si
corre la guardia lì poi corri corri
corri corri corri è chiuso le ho detto
che era chiuso
cosa succede
lui si fa uscire si sono cordio ovunque
fermi dobbiamo tieni condotto dell'aria
porco non regala troppe una ho mandato
giù
niente possibile raia di di notte
difficilissimo di notte non possiamo
ragazzi we try and they tried prendiamo
una lima prendiamo da mangiare e durante
il tempo libero
appoggiamo orale roma cosa mi ha proprio
fatto di me va bene pronti a ma andiamo
proviamoci dai che cosa abbiamo da
perdere
ci proviamo io dopo un altro a destra tu
sei la aspetta ma possiamo metterle lime
guarda è un'acqua guarda si ok c'è la
forza sua forza la sua fra siamo lo
abbiamo visto prima non posso uscire dai
arrivo arrivo
sono io vorrei deguara che so già quale
guardano quante ne aspetta la netta di
chi sta entrando come regalo se inter lo
mostriamo di botto ok allora fermo fermo
che ci vedeva il primo va ad ok ok lo
mangio non l'avete il biscotto vabbe dai
dire mi hanno sparato varie uscite
uscite cane cane dai laici sono più
possibile più possibile dai cc ora non
correre non importa adesso riprendiamo
la rima usciamo prima che per prima che
riparino sono già qua allora amici dove
vado forse riusciti a mio padre non ore
25 dai veloce taglia 25 eh sì by pietro
pietro libero pietro libero cgc ciò non
mi sono fatto uscire è si terra sono
terrore ma perché no ma sono fuori però
per prendermi faccio un buco sceglie la
cucina al buco non abbiamo tempo civili
ispirata da ciccio esatto il tradimento
continuo di mara che forse non ce la
facciamo ad avere una veramente aperto
ci credo ciao ciccio non possiamo uscire
ancora antico non so forse ci deve
essere anche cicciasan tv non si lasci
non si può uscire senza ciccio ma sopra
è però ci siamo fuori noi non c'è ancora
neanche scoperti viene velocemente dai
vieni vieni
no non la porta un amico ci sei mai così
tutti ti siamo come se non avessimo oggi
eccoli ecco i cinesi meritevoli o no le
guardie sì sì sì sì ce l'abbiamo fatta
noi
io vedo pietro io vedo pietro anch'io
anch'io avevo me stesso a ci sono quelli
del documentario che ci sta riprendendo
ti stiamo seguendo
no amici dai ce l'abbiamo fatta e sky
per
dal perimetro
[Musica]
sei anni che schifo che facciamo io non
ho preso ma ancora ho preso la fd fa
vigenti ma tu hai visto
va bene ci al prossimo episodio che ci
sto ci sto benissimo
chiediamo ha proseguito ragazzi che ha
visto video vite passate i canali 10
cioè piante descrizione cosa avresti
schietti e non ci vediamo alla prossima
invasione da ragazzi
[Musica]